- My next guest is a true
wonder girl herself at 14.
She is only 14 years old.
She's already written, produced,
and financed her own animated short film.
So sorry, all you adults out there
that that was your dream, and
you still haven't done it,
and a 14-year-old just showed you up.
It's called "The Power of Hope",
and it's catching the
attention of Hollywood Studios.
Take a look.
(upbeat music)
♪ We've got that power ♪
♪ We've got that power,
power, power of hope ♪
Please, y'all, give a big and warm welcome
to 14-year-old filmmaker Kalia Love Jones
and her father Gerald.
(audience cheering)
What's up?
Kalia, this film was
inspired by Michelle Obama.
It was a quote of hers.
Can you tell me a little
bit, what was the quote?
- Well Michelle Obama,
she's always been a
huge inspiration to me.
And I just love, she
has such a big influence
on so many people including me.
And I heard her speech, and in the speech,
she talked about overcoming obstacles.
And I really loved the message,
and I wanted to send that out as well.
And I thought it was important
that the film was animated
because I wanted to reach
an audience that was my age.
And also 'cause I just
love art and animation.
- Yeah, no, I think that
was really clever and smart.
Gerald, just to be clear,
she did all of this on her own, right?
- Yeah, this was 100% Kalia.
She took the reins and ran with it.
And I knew she was
passionate about filmmaking
at an early age because she
would always be drawing,
always do animation.
She'd ask for all these
apps to do it on her iPad.
And then one thing I noticed
that I thought was unique
is that she would watch an animated show
and watch the credits,
and then come to us and
say, "What is this job?
"What is that job?"
And she'd always have all these questions
that most kids would,
when the credits roll,
they just stop watching it.
- I've never heard one kid ask that.
That's awesome.
- She's been passionate
about it the whole time.
So when she came to us and said
that she wants to do this film,
we knew she was serious.
And we didn't have any
experience in the industry.
We don't know anybody in the industry.
So Kalia pretty much took
the reins and ran with it,
and we just were cheerleading her on.
- That's amazing.
Well, Kalia, it must've
been tough at times,
like you have never done
this kind of thing before.
Did you have any doubts
about finishing it?
- Yeah, I definitely did
doubt myself at times.
I felt scared.
I didn't like believe that
the movie would do well.
And I still do doubt myself.
- We all do, by the way.
- I still do doubt myself and get nervous
talking to a lot of people and
getting a lot of attention,
but I just have to keep going.
- Yeah.
Well mentors are important,
and I have some news for Kalia.
Her film caught the attention
of some pretty powerful women.
Let's get them in here.
Kalia, why don't you say hi
to "Wonder Woman" star Gal Gadot
and director Patty Jenkins,
who just so happens
to be the highest grossing
female director in history.
Both actually watched your short film.
And Gal, I'll start with you.
What impresses you about this young woman?
I am so impressed by her.
- You know what?
It blows... You just blew
my mind with this film.
It's so... I would never,
if someone would have
shown it to me before,
I would never imagine that a 14-year-old
can produce such a story.
But more than anything, the fact
that your inner compass is so in-tune
with all the good things
in the world blows my mind
because children in your
age, usually they care
about social media and
this and that and friends.
And they don't think about
the greatness of the world.
And you did, you do, and
this is beautiful to see.
And I have no doubt you're
gonna fulfill all of your dreams
because you're talented,
you're passionate,
you're a hard worker,
and you don't let anything
or anybody stops you.
And it just inspiring for me to see you.
So thank you so much for your work.
- Oh, my god, that was Wonder Woman.
I'm just saying, Wonder Woman
just like, "You're cool."
What about you, Patty?
'Cause you started at a young age.
You loved cameras.
You loved it, you knew at a young age.
But what about this?
At 12 years old, she started this.
- Yeah, I just want to
say congratulations to you
because I was so impressed
whatever the age is.
There was so much that I relate with there
because I very much have the same mission
of trying to make things
that put a message
that's very personal and
might inspire other people.
But even the way that you
say you chose animation
because you wanted it to be something fun
and that people can take in, so smart.
Listen, I felt like your
story was a self portrait
of a lot of people, but definitely myself.
It really, I had so much adversity.
I still have so much adversity.
I doubt myself.
I don't know that I'm
making the right decision.
But you're right, that beautiful speech,
and putting one foot in front of the other
and where you can make it to that way.
I can't believe I've made it where I have.
And I know that I'm not gonna...
I know that I'm going to see you again
if you keep putting one foot
in front of the other too
because you have everything,
you have the drive and the
will and the good heart
that you're really... That's
gonna guide you a long way
if you continue to want to do this.
- Yeah.
Are you freaking out?
I'm freaking out for you.
- [Gerald] I'm freaking out.
- You're freaking out, no, you're not.
- I'm like, "Don't cry."
- That's amazing.
- I'm just so proud of her.
- I know, and it's amazing to think
you brought her to this college campus
so that you could find animators
that came from her walking up
to these strangers to get help
to now sitting on this show
talking to Gal and Patty.
It's amazing what life can do,
especially when you focus
not on just the destination.
You focus on that journey
of getting it done
and doing what you love.
That's when I think you win every time.
And I feel like you're
one of those stories.
And I thank you so much
for coming on this show,
and thank you for sharing
your beautiful short film.
Yeah?
- Kelly, can I interrupt
with one more thing?
- Yes.
- I'm so sure that I'm
gonna see her again,
but I don't want to miss the
chance to make sure that I do
because I really like to meet
and inspire all young filmmakers.
So I wanted to know, would
you come and visit me
on the set of the next "Star Wars" movie?
- What?
That just happened!
That was not planned.
- Oh, my god.
- She's just awesome all on her own.
That was not planned.
- Yeah.
- Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh, are you down?
- Yes.
- If you need a chaperone-
- I'm chaperoning.
- If he's busy, if he's busy, I got you.
I can take you, I'll help you out.
No, that was so cool, Patty.
That was a beautiful thing.
And it is, it's actually funny
'cause we do a lot of that on this show.
We have women, we have call
it A Whole Lot of Woman.
We have this whole segment
called A Whole Lot of Woman,
and we have people in Patty's
position that are so powerful
and have earned it and
have worked their way up
and are trying to help younger
women achieve what they have.
And it's so funny that that just happened,
and we didn't plan that.
It just, she's just awesome.
And that was really cool.
Anyway, I'm freaking out, all right.